I'm just curious speaking of music what
was like your first concert because we
talked a lot with music with you okay
yeah so my first concert and I was
trying to think of this I think it was
Natalie Merchant whoa and I think my
friends and I choose to be the same age
yeah I was gonna say yeah she's playing
in Newport Rhode Island and I grew up in
Middletown Rhode Island my friends and I
rode our bikes and snuck into the
concert because it was outdoors and uh
saw our first concert I think I was
pretty young yeah wow what was your
first concert it was uh Prince Purple
Rain tour 1984.
yeah that's a good one yeah and and I
was only 23 now so I was a lot of In
Utero recollection of being in it you
know your first concert my first concert
that's a good start yeah
it's incredible I still remember oh my
God I still remember the white dove he
he traded the fender for the White Dove
guitar for Purple Rain it was just uh
still in my still in my mind grapes
right now what a
[Laughter]
you get all the time
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]